[Music]
instinct attracts news no I don't like
it stinky a trap I hate thinking what
does instinct think attracts though I
say thank you too I think so yeah I
never smell the piece of [ __ ] and go
didn't you talk to me like I'm a [ __ ]
two-year-old submitted by called fruit
Oh cold white person likes cold fruit
that's that's uh wait here
we gotta ask you do you use a fruit
basket what the [ __ ] is a fruit basket
there you go yeah Asian do you face hey
thank you put the fridge I thought you
were just giving me power another do you
put fruits in a fridge or do you have it
like outside
we have fruits both oh nana zombie else
but he's married to an ethnic Oh does
Nikki do that no I've always done like
that
oh I use II see that make sure who is
the person that's a deal vo no no but
it's not just field oh there's a lot of
my peers a light what like a lot of my
people that need a dance outside yeah
that's how I learned it from
so peaches apples everything yeah
outside that's fine outside oh of course
bananas outside I leave bananas and
oranges apples inside all my foods to be
as cold as possible this is what I'm
saying half the time when you guys like
all that's aging I'm like that's just
some other white people no but Theo was
saying that's that's a white people
thing and just also does it - yeah and I
learned it from Jeff root basket so they
throw it in the microwave before they
eat it so so was what ages do is they'll
buy a fruit basket and they'll put mail
in there they don't put fruits in there
we all put all our fruit in the fridge -
but yeah it's like a catch tray for all
minorities yeah they put mail inside the
fruit basket I see well maybe it's a
gentle thing
I know sometimes you guys like it's like
oh man like gum that's the total Asian
thing I'm like no the little gum is for
a little Asian teeth okay my Betsy yeah
single people are trying to find their
match using only their noses at
pheromone parties well that's pretty
cool
ty no no I'm not just about people what
if it's a dude I think that's pretty
yeah that's exactly what you go after
yeah but I need the whole package that's
like [ __ ] choosing someone based off
on the breath that's true
but you literally say you can't go out
with someone that smells bad but that's
a factor to the package it's not because
if she's bucking if she's gorgeous and
she stinks I don't think you can say
yeah but if she's [ __ ] butt-ass ugly
and she smells good see doesn't work
either let me tell you something really
she's hot enough you'll forgive anything
no you will I won't you will no have you
ever been attracted to someone and you
they smell nice but like their actual
pheromones like their their sense their
biological sense yeah like you're just
not I don't think I've ever felt that I
don't know how to exactly like put Nick
that out you know I mean it's like yeah
I don't either I think your pheromones
I'm scared to ask you this question
about who's the hottest woman on earth
to you
all right are we Jess it's the hottest
woman on earth
oh you're boring dude you from NYADA
yeah she watches this [ __ ] you're boring
dude no no you know what it is I
actually don't have like my goddess like
I don't have one well name five goddess
no no you might see the thing is I have
phases have you guys have you guys ever
have phases like depending on my mood
it's almost like food right so like I
can't say oh I love Japanese food
the best oh I can't say Korean food is
the best every year it's a little bit
different like I went through a very
skinny tall phase right like I liked
that and then I was like and then I went
to kind of like a fake-face but then all
across the board
I like booty that's what I realized okay
yeah and then sometimes big titties
little titties it don't really matter
know that swells like oh that's extra
credit for me so then I kind of put bits
and pieces together
but it's really hard for me to go one
person I idolize this one person it's
always just a general like oh I can't I
can like this person and the real
romantic and no no and here's the real
here's the reason why all I'm trying to
do is get you to say that somebody's hot
so I could say what if they stank and
then you would say you're right Steve's
just have a very simple human
conversation I don't need to know the
molecular [ __ ] structure of the
person that you're after see just like
who's the hot but instead you zoomed in
with the [ __ ] nuclear microscope it's
like what's your favorite food and I
ones that I like Cheetos I like whatever
and he's I can't name a favorite food
he's a top of the world I can't I can't
commit to that I can't commit to that no
no no
joke's on you pal I guess do something
that is very very precious to me I can't
do that if I may if I give you my word
that's gotta be it Larry King Larry
King's like get me another [ __ ] guest
please basic questions I want it like
like for example like let's say I think
Kate Upton has nice titties right and
I'm like okay where's a stink
what if they stink I don't care if she's
not your type what if they [ __ ] stay
is it for real body order
or is it because a dog took a [ __ ] on
her chest is that why she stinks no her
pheromone she stinks
oh okay with the darkness
yeah if a doctor fishing on her chest
I'll get a [ __ ] hose and I'll blast
that to actually try to put yourself in
the Kate Upton is sitting across to me
with her titties out and she's like come
here Joe
so and then when I come up when I come
up and I smell her yes and she's nasty
it smells not great you're a liar you're
a liar
David so Kate Upton's what type of smell
is it though because I sour milk that's
what I'm thinking I'm thinking the worst
kind of pheromone like you smell it and
you're like yeah smells kind of hard for
me but if I say don't say it don't say
it Kate Upton cuz I don't think Kate
Upton is that hot
who's your hardest about breaking it
down more like no gal gadot people
relate it to you so she's out now so
who's hot to you oh why you know me so
well sure cuz they know this [ __ ]
balls on or Ciera I don't know yeah
the stylee's thrown or we're talking
about like Katherine oh that's good hey
Marcus all my friend David likes the
classy [ __ ] Catherine Jones was
scorching [ __ ] yeah yeah it was wine
it's called steal my virginity that's
what that [ __ ] paper it's called a
journey ended this one thousand times
cuz like Catherine zeta-jones is sexy
she's pretty okay she smells she smells
now she smells [ __ ] ball once again
what does she smell like sour milk
sour milk and vinegar I would what did
she really do ready oh that's easy bro
that's an easy fix
see this thank you David thank you David
yeah right
liars yeah out of everyone in this room
I would have [ __ ] the nastiest
creatures so shut the [ __ ] up you know
what job cuz I would have actually done
it you guys talk it Joe you shut the
[ __ ] up because I would be in my [ __ ]
medicine cabinet
smelling [ __ ] ammonia whatever I gotta
do to make that [ __ ] go away oh my
[ __ ] nostrils dude I will [ __ ] come on
fire with a [ __ ] lighter dude you are
such a liar I would absolutely do that
for any of those [ __ ] for any of
those [ __ ] by the way all these guys
standards unbelievable Kate Upton get
that [ __ ] out of here oh my god you
would get on your [ __ ] knees
unbelievable no no no you just saying me
no I'm talking about him - that's how
bad smell to me Mel is that bad
came up that I don't find her attractive
at all I think she has nice boobs but
that's not my type I'm like I'm an ass
man so boot but that's not enough and
her face is like okay she had a flat ass
you know where she's beautiful but for
my type she ain't my type
I'll take her pressure hose is my type
classy regal but it looks like behind
this guy in the sheets she sucks good
dick I like it I'm with you but are you
guys understand this is [ __ ] funny to
me I don't know to me it's like
attractive or not attractive or not
would you [ __ ] him
yes or no that's it it's like if you're
attractive then yes yeah but smell is a
part of attraction for me well if you
ask me that's my character she's not
attracted to me I'm honestly I'm trying
David I'm disappointed in you
hey I still [ __ ] a lot of things people
are going to these pheromone parties all
over the country and what they do is
that they have to wear this clean white
plain t-shirt for four days and then
once they wear it for four days they put
it in a ziploc bag and then you go to
the party they assign you a number and
then they take a Polaroid photo of you
and then on that Polaroid photo you
start smelling t-shirts in these Ziploc
bags and then you get to pick out which
numbers you like like which pheromones
you like so you match that you match it
with the picture know the picture they
write down the number on it's like a
blind test yeah so then they write down
the number on your photo of which which
since you like and then you start
meeting these people at that party it's
pretty cool all during that party and
then they also encourage going up
directly to the person and smelling them
so then you're saying like in your neck
behind your ear it's like a Bob Clark
behind your ear yeah hopefully they wash
their I know you spread their butt
cheeks and go nope I don't like you I
don't think I would last turn in this I
could understand like the neck and
behind your stuff because like one night
when I hug Muriel that's why I like to
you too that's right that's right yeah
nuzzle up against her oh yeah that's my
favorite spot right here I love that
[ __ ] I smell that [ __ ] every day
mmm then they sense and when I'm kissing
Nicki like that her essence or something
about her essence like pheromone wise
that is I'm super [ __ ] now imagine
Nicki with a shitty smell
dude I'm into every time I'm in there
every time I'm beat that's a big part of
it though she smells good too you know
it's not it's not really it's just part
of it you know I'm saying the jeffer
have sex with Jess while camping and she
hasn't showered three Asians it smells
kind of nasty it's fine because her
pheromones are nice like her natural
body smell is attractive to me like so
then regardless if they're ranked or not
people just have a smell that's like oh
I can buy with that so it's not so
that's what I said the dog [ __ ]
reference earlier so I could watch dog
[ __ ] off
so her pheromones never get rancor the
Matt to me also it's always very
inviting to me like it's scrumptious if
you get prereq no I know I get rank
that's also I'll fail this test if I
were a white t-shirt like if you get
made it one day you'll destroy your
pheromones yeah if I get it was a one
day smell his side of the bedroom I
might get some matches mom but if after
wear this shirt for four days I'm not
going to no matches we 100% you know
unless definitely a nice just ding yeah
that's the thing yeah big fan like it's
like when you walk into a boy's room
versus a girl's room it just it smells
it's so great in the girls room but I
guys know how clean it is it still
smells like a [ __ ] guy not a lot of
Plus a dude - you're a heterosexual man
who's not attractive in females I mean
yeah sure a guy do stink
like their bathroom but like other guys
my final we won't find it as repulsive
as you because we're attracted to but I
don't know I do know thank God for that
well good smelt like you know like when
you like open like a Gillette like I
don't know a deodorant or shampoo it
smells clean right it's a man smell but
it smells clean
I take probably twice as many showers as
her and her bedside still smells a
million times better than mine yeah it
just smells like [ __ ] you know this
experiment this this pheromone
experiment depending on when the ladies
cycle ovulation is that's it it changes
what they find attractive all - yeah
Thank You birth control it changes their
form pheromones too
[Music]